calling all non-americans out there
maybe some Americans remember when we
did a tour I do we did a tour all across
America last year and a lot of you guys
especially outside of America are like
damn it I wish I could have seen it too
I wish I was in America hell there might
have been some Americans who missed out
on it well lucky you we are releasing
one of our shows just for you yes we are
releasing one of our
I should grab some of the merch that we
sold on tour that is all going to be
available for a very limited time with
one or two new pieces this is your last
chance to get tour merch guys so if
you'd like to check it out because again
it is limited access so get in quick
click the link down in the description
below to get your tickets now it's only
available for a limited time so don't
waste it hey so if you couldn't tell
from the title and theming of this
episode we won't be able to show you a
lot of the things that we talk about
because YouTube is run by a bunch of
Puritans so if you'd like to check out
the uncensored version of this episode
and support us in the process then make
sure to go over to patreon.com trash
taste links in the description below
foreign
s welcome back to another episode of the
trash taste podcast I'm your host for
today Joey because of course I'm the
host okay we didn't plan this somehow
someway whenever we have a episode
themed like this Joey just ends up being
the host it's like we didn't plan this
yeah why are you dressed why are you
dressed so nice because he's here for
the culture Corner that's why come on
Connor you you can't not dress up for
the hentai episode
in fact I am upset that I forgot my top
hat yes like the first episode we did
I'm sorry Connor I got the memo okay
actually ah you didn't even wear your
purple today after watching half the
stuff you told me to I don't think I
should ever I don't I'm gonna even know
how to leave my house let alone I don't
even think that stuff was legal anyway
I'm Joey and I'm with uh Conor and gone
as always and uh djen's Rejoice because
we are back I hate this podcast with
another episode for the culture
gentlemen watch any of this stuff for
whatever you guys I hate this actually
uh some of the stuff that you
recommended Connor May made me regret
life and maybe you want to commit
jumping so you know like I I'm I'm
before you say anything man I I felt the
same way
if you're all confused as to why we are
uh irrationally fearing uh the
inevitable it's because uh of the
challenge that we were given yeah this
is so much less fun than the other
episodes because last time I was like
here's a bomb hentai that I recommend
for me yes and then we just watched it
a brief moment where I had even a
semi-charb doing this like it was just
all pain yeah watching these shows this
was all pain so we uh decided to mix
things up from the previous episodes uh
the previous episode what we did uh in
regards to hentai was that we just
recommended three shows that we liked or
maybe it was too short again next yeah
we just recommended stuff that we liked
so we decided it's been a while since
we've done an episode like this let's uh
mix things up so each of us got two
categories each that we needed to
recommend a show in that category yeah
for the other boys to watch
um and then we would come and discuss it
and then at the end there would be one
really really cursed show that we would
all have to watch and discuss and the
show that we all decided on was Euphoria
I didn't I didn't decide on it all right
I've never seen this we'll get himself
do you want to go over what all the
categories are yeah sure so Connor got a
MILF hentai that he despised uh he
needed to recommend a MILF hentai he
despised in case he usually likes it was
hard to do yes and he needed to
recommend a hentai that made him cry or
just really depressed and uh that was
really easy watching that one was
actually really really interesting uh
Joey the uh nihongo Josie guy got a dub
hentai he actually likes that was the
biggest challenge there are so many
great ones which was I actually pretty
easy looking back it was um and he also
had to recommend the ugliest bastard
he's ever seen yeah which uh I just yeah
I mean I really had to comb through this
one let me tell you and uh that was that
was uh that was yeah oh my God and uh I
needed to recommend a hentai that awoke
something in me and also an NTR hentai I
actually liked and that was that was
hard that was that was very very hard to
say something I don't know I I just got
given a list of shows to watch I don't
know which one of these is which for you
and I'm concerned now
yeah you know I I saw this list and I
saw the recommendations that you guys
gave to me and I was like are you sure
about that like is this am I watching
the right show yes but we will get into
each one uh yes uh but uh first thoughts
how's your boys experience this time
this is it's just not fun at all yeah
you know usually it's terrible usually I
watch hentai and I feel good you know
for the most part you know 95 maybe 90
of the time I'm like all right this was
this was enjoyable to different you know
varying levels of of degrees but this
one was just like just sad I don't think
I can recommend any of these shows in
any capacity no I don't know for no
redeeming quality well we're gonna try
today we're gonna try because we have
some interesting shows I I feel like the
platter that we got this time was a lot
more varied than last time uh but I had
a lot worse of a time watching these
hentois last time there were a few that
I'm like I'm kind of I'm kind of digging
this right now you know Joey Joey got
some good recommendations come on
another MILF hentai okay now I'm just
like uh why am I watching this why am I
torturing myself yeah uh I am now like
this is basically just Sydney's channels
now you know yeah I I'm not paid enough
yeah but so I I cannot enough that this
is probably a one that you're going to
want to watch on the patreon yeah
there's gonna have to be a lot of
bleeping a lot of uh yeah self-centering
you won't be able to see anything that
we talk about but on the patreon you can
yeah okay on screen yeah okay so I guess
I should go first yeah you can go let's
go first uh let's stop what I think is
probably the mildest okay okay yeah
we'll start yeah yeah
the most chill yeah even then it was
weird so I got one which was uh name a
hentai or recommend a hentai that made
me cry almost made me sad yes and I
can't remember the name of this one it
took me like 30 minutes to even find the
name and then I'd copy and paste it and
send it to you I think it's called it's
called
and does that mean follow me to Studio
care land yeah yeah what it what is it
what's mizuru K line is it the author I
think mizidou care is the author oh okay
at least that's what from what I
remember because when I when I looked at
the title I was like in Japanese I was
like that doesn't really mean anything
it's just like the name of the amusement
park yeah so I guess I'll I'll explain
the the opening sure yeah explain the
premise of this shirt of this okay
so
um there is a land a theme park think
about uh uh you know your favorite theme
park now imagine if instead of that and
rides that you could ride you could ride
other people uh and the whole aspect of
this park was to sleep or engage with
fun activities with the other people
there yes and that was kind of the
premise and then two boys are like yo
let's go let's go let's go to the land
boys
however in real and then obviously we
also see uh two female characters who
are also interested one of them he was
three right yeah or three one of them
you know they're all different
personalities one of them's a bit more
shy but like oh I don't know
like all right I'm ready I'm ready to
get down and dirty I'm about to go dicko
mode yeah like and so obviously in real
life this happened it would be a sausage
fest and yeah yeah a grinder world yeah
somehow it's uh equally distributed in
terms of like both girls and boys yeah
it's the most well-managed theme park in
existence I actually I actually made
notes this time that's good I wish I
made notes but I was so annoyed I didn't
want to write it and literally my first
the first note I made was finally a way
to get Joey to enjoy Disneyland
no he hates theme parks I hate
steampunks and I was like oh finally a
theme park that Joey and Joey would
enjoy let's let's talk the first five
minutes of this show okay I was kind of
I was kind of into the premise I was
kind of like I was kind of like yeah
this I'm into this yeah they explained
they explained the theme park animation
was solid as well
I will say because like like going into
this obviously the categories are hentai
that made you cry and I was like this is
this is really [__] vanilla for like
where's the where's the crime coming man
where where is the crying coming and
yeah like like I was saying earlier like
you know some sometimes I I looked at
the show and I looked at the the
category I guess that are fit in and I'm
like I don't know if I'm watching this
correct show yeah because I finished
episode one of this and I was like
what made me cry
I had the exact same reaction I was like
dude my my eyes were drier than a desert
there was not a single tear welling up
at one point does this make you feel
like sad not really dude I felt so empty
when I finished this I was like that is
the saddest [__] I've ever seen if
anything all the other shows made me
feel sad I I was yeah I would agree with
that okay okay okay but anyway yeah
let's explain the plot so so there's two
boys on a bus and there's three girls on
the same bus they don't know each other
yet all right but but the boys are like
yo tits out for the boys let's go we're
about to we're about to go Deco mode and
the girls are like all right you know we
got a friend who's like you know hasn't
done this before but you know what we'll
we'll ease her into this stuff up yeah
and uh the explanation in the theme park
and how it worked I was like oh
this is legit like this is this is the
most this is the best management of
theme parks I've ever had yeah this
theme park runs better than Disneyland
does somehow they got an entire like
sticker system in this theme park you
have like three tiers so you can either
have like a sticker that says you're
okay with kissing uh there's a sticker
that says you're okay with touching and
then there's a sticker that says full-on
penetration baby let's go and of course
no one does the kissing sticker we don't
we don't follow kisses here everyone
goes for like full-on Deco mode right
here
um and then yeah and everyone's wearing
like the weirdest outfits oh yeah the
the dude's outfits were so strange I'm
like so bizarre because they're wearing
this like it the only thing the only way
I can describe it is like you know that
bikini that Borat wears yeah yeah they
were wearing that except imagine that
but the dick is just fully out and then
the one of the dudes wearing like
chapless pants yeah his ass is just out
or something it's just like all right
on the bus here wearing that do you know
why I found really weird so it was that
scene where they were like explaining
what was going in the theme park right
and these dudes are just having a normal
conversation and one of the dudes is
just like casually jacking off while
he's like talking to the other dude
he's just having a pro talk at one of
them best friends yeah
and I was like I was watching this I was
like this is just Next Level Onsen you
know this is what happens if you go to a
nonsense
you're in the onset all three boys pop a
Viagra and one of them and we're just
like yo boy it hasn't been so far yeah
how's it been how's your tripping so far
man so weird I was just like it's like I
think I think what made it like I think
well maybe kind of weird is is how they
explain the rules in a way that would
feel a bit more realistic because a lot
of hentai just doesn't even bother
trying to even remotely explain the
words yeah right they're like you're in
the same world except this guy's a chat
or something yeah yeah uh I think that's
what was kind of like all right okay
kind of I was kind of like precarious
but I was like all right well this seems
kind of okay speaking on that though
what I did find was kind of like okay
it's so good at my expectations a lot it
did it did like a weird way
to go where it went this is the most
I've ever seen Connor analyze any piece
of media I think this is the first time
I've ever heard the word connoisseur
expectations well listen it's a it's a
the thing with with modern day of this
kind of stuff you watch let's say live
action Western of this production yes
yes yes yes
um you know exactly when you drop that
time bar you know roughly what you're
gonna be on when you let go yeah yeah
yeah with this one I was like where is
this going like what is I thought this
dude was gonna get some gonna go wild
that is not what happened that is not
what happened at all yeah so we have two
two different groups and the first scene
the main guy and the main girl did I
believe but yeah at this point it
doesn't matter yeah so the main gun the
Mean Girl are both like kind of like
this is their first time in a theme park
and their friends are like veterans
they've been yeah and they're like the
kind of like yeah yeah and so the first
the first big scene takes place on a
ferris wheel where what happens by the
way there's a brilliant [__] pun in
the Japanese version okay it shows up
because in in Japanese uh Ferris wheel
is called the kandansha right right but
they changed the kanji of Khan and dung
to normally it means like you know um
viewing uh spinning yeah yeah right in
this
they changed it still says but now it's
the kanji for Roth [__]
that's good it's like going to the
so the first scene is uh two random
people get on this ferris wheel in like
one two main characters yeah so so the
two main characters end up seeing each
other and they've seen each other before
they see they see each other briefly
um
yeah yeah
they see each other on the bus and of
course they meet on the ferris wheel
um and I think for like of of course
they do the deed
um and I think for him he's just he he
is in the wrong [__] place man he's
in love with this girl this man went to
a soap land to look for a wife man yeah
yeah yeah he he like it's I think he
just instantly like Falls for this girl
yeah in the ferris wheel or even maybe
on the bus right yeah and they seem to
have some chemistry going together
and you know it's all pretty I'd say
vanilla stuff not nothing I haven't seen
out the ordinary it's just a casual
casual orgy every now and again you know
there is a casual there is there is a
weird scene before this where one of the
girls is getting their vaginas cleaned
and I'm just like that's one thing I
wanted to say right like so they explain
like the rules of the theme park right
where it's like oh you have to wear a
sticker and it's like and one part I
thought was weird was like okay so uh so
that diseases don't spread all the guys
and girls have to get checked and like
the girls have to get like cleaned out
by this like [__] special host and
and I just looked at that I'm like
that's copium because everyone knows by
the end of it you are diseased off yeah
yeah yeah like there's no helping like
this is this is just like nothing's
gonna come out of this yeah look we we
this is a fantasy world everyone on
Craigslist have had money and they all
pulled together to make a Craigslist
location IRL yeah
um and so if things start getting weird
where it basically turns to a kind of
swingers party right there were like two
two of the groups yeah yeah one
experienced guy one was a girl and then
the two main people who are the girl and
the guy who can yeah the newbies yeah
yeah and uh through the throughout the
course of the show the girl turned from
like being this I'm a shy innocent cute
girl to uh yeah I'm I'm kind of like I'm
kind of like really perverted yeah I
kind of I'm secretly like this yeah yeah
it's uh it's she has two wolves inside
of it
uh and uh during the swinger scene is
when we see words we see the darker
Wharf inside of the second girl right so
they they've they both start off you
know with their respective partners that
they've found from this uh from this
Ferris wheel and then they start doing
the deed next to each other I knew where
it was gonna go as well yeah they
basically do a wife swap essentially
yeah yeah and he's and you know he the
the main character is having a lovely
time of of course he's a bang this girl
they have chemistry together
and then uh and then the swap happens
yeah they swap because one of I guess
the other two feel done and they're like
yeah swap yeah yeah let's spice things
up and you're like no no this dude
doesn't want to swap yeah yeah
is that what made you sad it made me sad
because it's like you're watching porn
but you're watching like the realest
like saddest emotion where it's like
this dude is just in this situation he
doesn't want to be in listening to the
girl he likes one foot away from him
getting pounded and she's enjoying it
more with him yeah and she is with with
uh with the with the other guy Sergeant
himself yeah it's like how am I supposed
to jack off to this like this guy's just
getting sad like this guy used to just
destroyed he's just realizing that the
girl he like fell for and the girl he
lost his virginity to yeah it's just
loving getting pounded by this other guy
yeah who's clearly way better at this
than him and he doesn't know and then
this other girl is like consoling him
and the one who like was just had it
rough she's like don't worry man some
people will just like it a little chill
don't worry some people like it that
you're a little [__] you don't know
what you're doing and it's like this is
just this is just the saddest thing why
am I why am I okay now you put that into
that context I understand why this is in
this category and it's like how the [__]
we should get off to this when all I'm
thinking is dude this is like at least
if it was some absurd kind of stupid
plot I would be like all right whatever
but like it's just like just sad like a
sad thing that could just that could
happen
is it a crazy that like we look at a
show like this and we explain a plot
like this and we're like this isn't
absurd
yeah
why are you trying to convey this yeah
like what do you get from this yeah
this the thing that made me
uncomfortable about this is that it is
NTR this is essentially NTR but it's
it's it's it's soft enough it starts
vanilla and then kind of goes into it I
think it's at least with NTR I'm like
I'm like yeah this is just [__] this
is dumb this is just stupid and it's
like yeah yeah it's unrealistic but the
thought of liking a girl and maybe it
turns out she doesn't like you as much
as you thought that's that's the thing
it's NTR that hits a little too close if
you're like together like they weren't
together
but the thing but the thing that hits a
little too close to home is that he they
weren't together but he liked that girl
a little too much and a little too
quickly you know like he was out of his
depth yeah he probably shouldn't even
been there exactly like he knew he was
gonna get hurt yeah that's just sad it's
just sad how do you know how did you
watch that and be like I feel nothing
how how because I think I looked at it
and I compared it to every other NTR
I've seen and I'm like yeah it gets sad
everyone can relate to the feeling of
maybe you liked someone yeah maybe they
turned out to like someone else yeah
right exactly I think that's a very very
a human thing that most people have
experienced I think the Saving Grace for
me is that it's only one episode so
you're not as invested in these
characters if that happened at like
episode three then I'd be like oh this
is my God this was a 15 minute episode
as well it's two episodes of the second
episode has nothing to do with those
characters no thank God yeah
um but like yeah it's just like
this is so [__] sad yeah because it's
sad I think the saddest thing is that
this guy is basically just having a
therapy session wow as his trauma is
happening next to him right there the
girl that he fell for is just like
having us she's having a time of hers
having the time of her life because the
worst thing is that she said oh you know
I like you as well you know I feel like
we have a connection and then five
minutes later she's [__] getting
railed by this other guy who's doing a
completely better job and and this
girl's just like oh don't worry are you
it's not the size of matters it doesn't
matter and I guess and I guess the extra
like sad part is that like that was his
bro yeah like like this is the dude
that's like yeah bro we're gonna have a
great time together
like hey man I I really like that girl I
really don't want to do it yeah but then
also like I don't know it's [__]
stupid it's such stupid
it is to me like it is framed in a way
that uh it it is kind of the guy's fault
for
yeah because like even like the girl he
fell for she said going to this place
looking for some looking for a
connection is gonna get you hurt because
people here are not here for that
[__] yeah it's totally awesome
sympathize because you kind of follow
him yeah and yeah you can you can all
sympathize with liking someone who
really didn't like it yeah and then
what's the worst [__] thing
busting is after this happens after she
finishes getting railed and obviously
has a better side of him in front of him
after all that trauma is happening as
well right he asks her out I think oh
yes that was the saddest thing I
completely forgot about that just I just
lost I just yeah how pathetic how
pathetic do you have to be to watch that
feel those emotions be like can we still
please beat again that's true yes as
he's confessing and like trying to
trying to profess to this girl that like
no no like this is legit like I actually
connect with you on an emotional level
she's like would you still love a girl
who loves getting [__] down by random
dudes and he's like hell yeah babe and
I'm like don't do it bro it's like yes
I still love you like it's so pathetic
and it's so sad like Joe I wanted to
[__] cry after watching I'm like that
is the saddest [__] I've ever seen like
you know how pathetic do you have to be
and what what a skeptical and sad way of
viewing relationships like this this
this series was yeah yeah so if you made
this like what is why what's going
through your head it's it's like the man
huffed so much copium he could like Huff
the entire atmosphere of Earth like it's
he was I don't know what he was thinking
when he just said oh yeah I just uh
obviously just have a trauma I just saw
the girl get [__] down now let's let's
ask her out let's say yeah this is the
perfect time to confess my love to this
girl
okay yeah now when you put it in that
perspective it makes sense yeah how did
you watch that and feel nothing because
again my mind has just been corrupted by
all the NTR I've seen and I'm like it
can get worse I know ntl's just [__]
weird I gotta say it's not the most
[__] up thing I've seen it's not the
saddest thing I've seen but it was just
kind of like surreal no it wasn't it
wasn't too real follow the character
that you every I think it's the main
character right because I think we've
all known someone like that yeah yeah
someone who innocently gets into bad
situations sometimes and some someone
who maybe Falls for a girl a little too
fast yeah and you're like you you try to
tell them bro don't do it okay this is
bad for you don't do it and they do it
anyway oh also I just remembered as well
like after he confesses and like after
she does like all of the yeah but do you
still love me if XYZ and they decide to
have intercourse again then she's like
it's so funny we don't even know each
other's names
as he's inserting she's like I don't
even know your name
whack like everything is out of order
here yeah yeah honestly like I don't
know why she said yes as well I guess
she's she they're both they both suck
yeah they both suck as human beings yeah
yeah like yeah she's obviously I don't
even know if she's like consciously
leading him on this we've done this into
a [__] character study by the way the
only chat on this is the woman who got
railed and then just kind of like
sympathetic towards yeah yeah yeah she's
yeah she's like the only no the only the
only Giga chat in that show was the
[__] blonde girl who was getting
[__] down by three dudes at the
beginning she's like just just leave me
be I'm good yeah I'm good you guys go
have fun you know at least the girl was
sympathetic to this innocent kid you
know and and and try to like talk him
down but at that point it's like what
what can you say what can you say
he's these two friends I don't know man
I don't even feel like she was being
sympathetic she just literally just did
like a Gigi no real like
yeah I mean happily like I did end up
watching the second episode as well yeah
um which is very different just because
I was like Curious is there is there a
happy ending for the story there is no
happy ending to this story because it's
a completely different story right um
the second episode focuses on like a
group of Idols
one thing that actually impressed the
[__] out of me right is okay the the
um the premise of the episode is that
there's a group of Idols that perform at
this theme park and of course they have
a kind of like handshaking kind of event
except it ain't handshaking it is uh it
is digging down the dick and down event
where you get one minute per per
handshake or per dick Shake I'll say God
um but what one thing that really
[__] impressed me they made a full-on
Idol song for this man they made a
full-on Idol song for episode two I'm
like where are you getting this
production values from man yeah sure
looks amazing yeah yeah it's really well
done oh no yeah the animation was good
character designs were good which makes
me more angry because it could have been
a good MILF one and so we got this it's
always NTR man yeah that gets a good
[__] the one time where you're like
where's Queen be at yeah when we needed
him most he disappeared yeah like I did
I didn't cry towards this but I will say
I didn't feel I just felt like I felt
impressed it was literally the the you
know that that image that's popular the
one with the scribbledon dude who's like
oh yeah
yeah that's how made me feel like I was
just like dude now for me it was the
horse on the beach with the man yeah man
that's how I fell after that man very
much
come on so don't watch it yeah don't uh
don't don't watch that don't want that
one ladies and gentlemen we are
interrupting this program for a very
special announcement because this video
is sponsored by boxer it is the month of
March which means it's time for Sakura
season and thankfully the sakuras the
cherry blossoms have started to bloom in
Japan but it's also understandable that
a lot of you can't be here in Japan
right now to enjoy the cherry blossom
season and so that's why boksu is here
to give you guys a little taste of Japan
in the comfort of your own home boxer
delivers the experience of tasting
authentic Japanese snacks candies and
tea sauce directly from centuries old
small family businesses right to your
door their mission is to empower Japan's
traditional snack makers by sharing
their authentic food and stories with
the world and you better believe that
this month we have the Sakura story box
filled with all sorts of Sakura themed
as well as cherry blossom viewing snacks
and tea pairings for example we have one
of my favorite soccer themed snacks
Sakura Mochi look at this thing it's
like if Kirby turned into a snack they
say the perfect snack doesn't exist well
I just happen to find it and why not
wash it down with this month's tea
pairing this is the kangoshima shiranja
which is a special type of green tea
that is made specifically in the
kagoshima prefecture so if you'd like to
experience just a little bit of the
Sakura season from the comfort of your
own home and support the show in the
process then make sure to go down to the
link in the description below to get
yourself your own box suit and make sure
to use our coupon code trash taste at
checkout to get 15 off your boxu order
thinking about suit for sponsoring this
episode this episode of trash taste is
sponsored by gamer Subs let's be honest
sugar is a thing of the past if you need
an energy drink with zero crashes zero
sugar and tastes amazing then gamer Subs
is for you that's right this Justin I'm
receiving this correctly this is zero
calorie Energy Formula and it's keto and
diabetic friendly it's a guilt-free
energy drink that you can drink
throughout the day and it keeps you calm
and alert and if you don't need energy
you can just cut out all that sugary
crap and replace it with this right here
I have the titty milk flavor and yes you
heard that crackly titty milk and for
some reason it tastes good and they have
some other weird flavors like guacamole
gamer fart I'm I'm reading that out
correctly I I am indeed okay well that
way if you would like to try that then
put please use the link in the
description down below and let us know
down below if you'd like any other weird
flavors that we might make ourselves and
if you want to try some of this product
they will ship you a free sample pack
that will ship worldwide and it's on us
just order completely free so if you
want to get some free samples yourself
or you want to grab some of the titty
milk check out gamersubs.gg trash taste
and use coupon code trash taste to get
free shipping for your sample pack that
is gamersups.gg trash taste back to the
episode speaking of NTR I guess we're
just let's just continue the NTR terrain
because I had to recommend an NTR I
actually enjoyed okay and I recommended
them uh what's the name again
which means NTR wife yeah so
okay why did you choose this one okay
okay so for the record I [__] despise
NTR I die I think yeah I think I think I
think we all despise NTR yeah right and
I remember the first time I saw this I
was like the name has Network in the
name yeah there is no [__]
possibility this can end well I'm
surprised you even clicked play with the
time
yeah but
the reason I the the reason this is the
closest thing I've come to an NTR
what the reason why this is the closest
thing I've found to an NTR I enjoy is
because I was [__] happy that this
dude got empty yard right this dude this
dude
pissed me the [__] off like the dude
that gets empty yard actually like
pissed me off do you want to explain the
problem okay so the premise is okay so
there is there is a main guy the main
girl obviously and they're a married
couple and the dude is an idol fan right
Richard that's right yeah yeah yeah the
dude is an idol fan and he is obsessed
with this one Idol right he is so
obsessed that he he found his wife
because his wife reminds him of this one
item like they're identical yeah they're
they're almost identical looking so
[__] up and when they're having and
when they're having sex he doesn't refer
to his wife by his wife's name he refers
to her as his Idol's name his favorite
Idol's name role play yeah manager and
like producer
yeah essentially he's incapable of
getting hard unless she role plays as
his favorite Idol yeah right and I'm
like that's [__] up what a [__] that
[__] I'm I remember seeing that I'm like
she deserves better and of course one
day his like one of his one of his
friends comes over and she explains the
situation that she's in yeah and if and
of course he's like well if you want to
if you want if you want a man to treat
you right I'm right here it's the first
time I've ever seen an NTR and I'm like
wow the guy ntring has the right opinion
no yeah wait he's like where he's like
no because at the beginning when she's
like yeah so my husband and I do this
thing when we have intercourse and he's
like wow that's [__] up and I'm like
you know what kind of agree yeah I mean
I think that everyone is [__] up in
this in this show yeah of course it uh
the wife probably uh
I mean she should have left him straight
out oh yeah oh yeah so I'm sorry but
like did you really marry the guy who
was only into you because you look like
like I I feel like that's a little bit
on you I'm like how did you not did you
not think about that before you sign
those like you know marriage papers like
yeah this has never come up in
conversation obviously we're looking way
too much into this yeah um and I am
because we're reviewing it yes
um but it man man it was bad yeah yeah
like there's there's uh
the fact that it had to be his like
friend like his his his childhood friend
who comes over and this dude is clearly
a scumbag yeah of course she has the
scumbag they give him the traditional
anime
and the tanned skin and blonde hair yeah
which is tradition if there are two
things that speak NTR
ugly bastard and tanned blonde hair [__]
I don't know [__] the [__] boy yeah
right I don't know why I don't know why
it's just like this is you do the Idol
guy this is your childhood friend this
guy yeah that's what I was questioning
I'm like how did you guys become friends
like is he like a formal Idol fan or
like did you just see him on the street
so like what like what is the connection
yeah and then and then so yeah like
obviously uh the they're having uh
dinner together and the main guy uh the
husband passes out yes as he does as he
does because he's like drunk yeah and
then uh they start talking the the wife
and the friend yeah and obviously they
explain and obviously he's like bro what
the [__] I'm instead of just having it
as bro what the [__] he's like bro what
the [__] let me get in on that I mean
let me show you I have a radical
solution
I like and so they just start doing it
and it's like okay I mean I guess but
they stopped doing it in front of him
sleeping and then that's one thing I've
never understood about like not just NTR
hentai but like even NTR like javs yeah
right because that's such a common
situation it's also normal important
like yeah obsession with people sleeping
I don't know I think it's the Forbidden
aspect of it but why does it have to be
that and I'm like how are you not waking
up that's what okay of course there are
there are I get the chlorophyll thing
but like you know which sometimes
happens
you know when you get chloroform then
you just like knock the [__] out but
it's like I never thought I'd hear that
out of course I get the chloroform thing
what's that sleeping thing that's a bit
too funny how deep can your sleep be
where where your wife is getting rare
failed literally centimeters from your
face and you're just like well no no
he's sweet dreams this dude is railing
her so hard that her you know her
um I don't know how to describe it
juices are going on his face and he's
not waking up yeah exactly yeah and I
was like am I supposed to be turned on
by this because I'm just suspending
every disbelief that this guy is asleep
yeah yeah I mean I'm screaming monitor
like work out wake up you know I it
would have been so much more fun no I
kind of wish he woke up I would have
been so much better you know because
like I I'm this is the reason I
recommended this was because this is the
one NTR that unfortunately doesn't have
an episode too and I wanted this to
happen episode two because you know what
I'm I watch this and I'm like they did
not go far enough I need to [__] off I
need to see this [__] guy in tears
crying okay okay they did not go far
enough I agree he sucks but I don't
think he deserves that
I feel this show in the five stages of
grief we're still in the denial phase
you know he doesn't deserve the wife but
I don't think he deserves to have his
whole life shattered in front of him
I've
the dialogue was weird like they were in
a full-on conversation while going at it
yeah and she's like we should we should
become sex friends and it's like what
and he's like okay dude just break up
with yourself my favorite my favorite
thing about it is like at the end when
like when it finishes and then there's
that final scene of the husband you know
doing the same thing to the wife right
but this time the wife is like all I
have to do is build up my frustration
and I'll be able to release it I'm like
what is this like this is like the
Pokemon move bide you know where you
just like wait five times
like why why you what do you what are
you getting from this just get out of
this goddamn message get the divorce
papers bro I mean I agree she should
never have ended up with this guy in the
first place but you know as as the
married man here I'd be like you know if
I did that to Sydney [__] like I I don't
deserve Sydney you know like like
we know aren't you doing that though she
looks like the anime character what's
that one Myron yeah isn't he just doing
that with Marion uh excuse me we've been
dating for eight years actually
yeah I just I'm just like I don't know
why you would want to be with a girl if
if you want to be with a girl just
because she reminds you of someone else
you're a [__] beta man you you
deserve you deserve bad things to happen
to you and you know what I like I
watched this and I was like I'm [__]
happy the ntr's happening in fact
they're not going far enough this guy
should have woken up he should have got
his dream shot I believe he should have
woken up yeah because I think the
ensuing plot would have been more
exciting oh yeah because I I feel like
what was I feel like really disappointed
because they obviously set themselves up
for an episode two they obviously set
themselves up for a sequel where they
like mind break this guy yeah mind break
mind break this [__] beta and then
they didn't do it and then they didn't
do it I'm like this is the one time I've
actually wanted a sequel to an NTR and
you don't give it to me you don't give
it to me go on guys do people like mind
break
oh
that's why do people like my question
why do people like Minecraft why do
people want to see a man like just an
entire world no no my mind break I think
goes like both ways so there's like you
know when the girl has a mind break
where like the sex is so good it like
breaks their minds yeah and then like
and I I mean I used the wrong
terminology but there's just like NTR
where you just like it's not that's
that's not mind break that's just
depression yeah that's just like [__]
ruin someone's life that's just that's
just yeah
there's a difference between mind break
and mental break
bro I need a [__] mental break after
watching half these shows
uh let's let's go on to my first one
which was uh the one that has an ugly
boss in it
because uh I definitely had a [__]
mental breakdown after I watched this
one I had a mental breakdown on two
separate occasions yeah challenge again
so my I mean the ugliest boss the
ugliest episodes I've seen yes
um and trust me uh whether I like it or
not when you're when you're perusing
through the the wide world Cesspool of
hentai you will come across ugly bosses
whether you like it or not yes and uh
and so I was like all right what's the
worst one and so I went with uh a hentai
called um
which is in Japanese it means even still
I love my wife
this
this is actually completely confusing
because when you recommended it there
are actually like two two of these right
yes this this is actually this is
one with multiple episodes and then
there's a second season
yeah with different characters
to watch one but I actually watched both
as well oh really and I regret it yeah
so so I recommend I recommend the second
one the second season because uh in the
second episode the second season second
season yeah
um because it has an ugly bastard which
I'm sure if you've been on any Twitter
before you've definitely seen the ugly
bastard in this yeah
yeah yeah I had that's that's the main
that's what I mean when I said I had two
different types of mentality yeah one
because the show was just goddamn
horrible and two because I was like oh
my God this is where this guy comes from
I've seen this image of this
[__] so many times this is the
one
um so basically also the other mental
breakdown I had was just how convoluted
the plot dude I I had man it's like you
know when you read a book and you read a
line you're like I gotta take that in
again yeah I did that so many times and
I was so confused so so if I can
remember correctly there is a a husband
and a wife all right I mean are they and
they already and their teacher yeah and
so the student or what no no no no so oh
my God so there is a husband and a wife
the wife is a teacher at a college yeah
right and the college teacher the wife
is in cahoots with one of her students
who looks exactly like her husband but
but her husband also looks like a kid as
well but her husband also looks like a
kid like it's so confusing yeah it's
like a younger version of her husband
yeah but basically that she's in she's
so while like he's on a [__] business
triple no no she goes to work in a
different School far away oh yeah that's
right yeah so yeah so the life goes to
work far away at the school but they're
still mad but they're still married yeah
but because she's far away she sees this
student that looks exactly like her
husband and goes like you know I feel a
bit lonely at work because we're always
so literally like one minute in one
minute one minute in yeah and the guys
and the student is like don't worry
teach I I got you bro yeah and then they
start and basically the husband the
husband gets NTR yeah and then there's
this weird like B plot when it goes to
the husband's perspective yeah yeah
there's this other girl who's introduced
and she's kind of friendly with him yeah
uh and that doesn't really go anywhere
for a while until she drugs him yeah at
the end of the day episode she drugs him
and then it cuts but yeah but like
that's right at the end yeah like
obviously but basically so basically the
wife and and the teacher having and the
student are having this like very secret
intimate relationship and the owner of
the apartment who is the ugly bastard in
question manages to snap a picture of
them kissing right and basically leave
the building yeah and basically uses
that as blackmail to be like Hey so uh I
saw you having sexual relations with
this student you don't want the teacher
you don't want the school to find out
right you know what you got to do I feel
like people are having an easier time
following the plot of inception right
now there are like so many different
things
and man is this guy the ugliest of
ugliest okay
I am pretty sure I am pretty sure okay
that this hentai was made in order to
limit test boners okay it's it's because
okay here's the thing first five minutes
this is a A plus hentai okay you got a
hot teacher you gotta know you like the
ntring of the the student sorry you like
the NTR part with the student the answer
like at this point the husband hasn't
been introduced right well we we I guess
we had a little bit of the husband a
tiny bit no we don't we don't really get
not enough to care about no no we don't
care okay you know that's that's it's
it's like a little bit of light cheating
you know it's it's it's it's different
from NTR all right it's not full it's
it's like not full on NTR evaluation is
good it has no right the animation is
good it looks [__] incredible the
teacher is like an st dude I watched
this [__] in 1080P yeah I was like I
almost wished it didn't exist yeah the
teacher is is great yeah yeah great
talks and does things I I was like this
this is this is this is great and then
you get the shot of the ugly bastard and
I swear this shot of the ugly boss I
know the one you're talking about yeah
yeah yeah it's vile it's it's the sh
it's the full body shot of the ugly
bastard and I swear to God I could hear
Dark Soul music when like the shot comes
on it's this so correct this man is the
final boss of ugly bastards the [__]
Health Partnership
yeah when he shows up it's just like my
I remember the first time takes up the
whole frame
yeah he takes up the whole frame yeah
yeah because like I remember like I've
I've seen my fair share of ugly bastards
but the first time I watched this my jaw
dropped to the floor it was like that
that that's who that's who they
introduced that's that's a person yeah
that's a real person that ain't a person
okay yeah I mean some of these shots
some of these shots like were framed and
I swear to God she was [__] she was like
[__] a Titan oh dude okay that was my
nitpick with like the first like NTR
scene with the ugly bastard I got more
than nitpicks there's this there's
different shots of like you know them
[__] doing whatever and they can't
stay consistent with the size of this
dude because there's one shot where he
looks like 12 feet tall and then there's
another one where he looks like you know
the Hunchback guy from 300 like he kind
of looks like that guy and I'm like why
are you like what's happening I had to
skip through the sex scene I couldn't
watch it it was good
no you needed to watch the sex scene to
feel the pain no I didn't want I
couldn't do it I couldn't do it yeah it
was it was gross it was bad like you
know in some scenes of Attack on Titan
where there's like a really really small
Titan with a really big head
now like you might imagine Like a Porn
version of that and that's what this
anime was that was this what the sex
scenes was like this man this man is
literally the embodiment of pot of greed
you know you he has a pot of green face
he has a pot of greed face man and then
like they do it and then I guess the
student comes back and then there's the
teacher's like well the journal is like
the ugly bastard guy's like well join in
and the kid's like ah okay
and it's like what the [__]
yeah I didn't understand that conclusion
that was so weird like like this student
would watch this and be like all right
okay if
you insist it's just like it's just
disgusting like everything was
disgusting yeah so two got like 10 times
more disgusting episode two was just
weird because I I don't know why they
tried adding in subplots yeah yeah they
added like a b plot and a c plot to it
I'm like I'm still confused from the
first episode because I was trying to
treat like I in my in my mind uh to try
to cope with like what like the
atrocities that was like I was viewing
one screen Geneva Convention somehow I
don't know which one but they broke
something yeah I was I was just trying
to keep back uh keep track of uh so how
many people are getting into yard right
now everyone was getting into yeah yeah
yeah it was just like nobody was like
why don't you all just just call it a
day no relationships no one is allowed
because this clearly isn't working in
this universe yeah so originally it's
the husband I guess NTR because the
because the teacher is uh is finds a
student who the student is also in love
with the teacher right so at the
beginning it's the husband getting into
yards but then it's the student and the
husband getting into yard because we
find the ugly bastard but then the
husband finds a yandere who drugs him
and so the husband starts having sex
with the yandere so it's the teacher
getting into you hold up hold up he
doesn't he is very much not doing it
voluntarily she drugged him ties him up
and then she makes him watch a video of
her husband being destroyed by a dude
and then he's just like drugged out of
his mind being taken advantage of yeah
that is growth they included this like
they included this weird B plot which I
didn't understand which is like while
the husband is getting inside by this
yandere yeah and they play the video of
the wife explaining like the reason why
she's willingly getting into yard is
because like the husband is in like a
bunch of debt or whatever and then it
turns out the ugly bastard is like some
kind of in in he's involved in some kind
of like yeah
any cigar and the gold teeth I'm like
where the [__] did this come why are you
doing a janitorial which I felt like for
some reason the first one was wildly
popular in Japan yeah and they were like
bro we need a sequel he's like bro that
was not supposed
and then they're like all right well
let's make something yeah and then they
made this [__] yeah it's honestly if
this was like this was terrible it was
bad like I cannot recommend to not watch
this enough this is so gross so vile I
mean like like just just awful we can
all agree it's the ugliest boss of we've
all seen it is the ugliest boss okay
there is the reason why this guy has
become a meme everywhere if when you
search the term ugly bastard his face
will show up because I would like to see
if we can find an ugly boss uglier
bastards because I think after that
you're just in like like isekai Goblin
territory I'm like yeah I had this uh
weird memory where um I actually
realized I watched this the second one
this only the second episode I've
watched it before okay right maybe watch
the first thing you just like no it was
like trauma and you just blanked it from
your memory I definitely haven't because
I remember I'd watch the second episode
thinking it was like the first episode
of something and I was really confused
yeah um and I think it put me off hentai
for like like
because I was like I was like when they
got to the like the twist of like he'd
been this yandere been doing the thing
to him for so long that he just now is
not even of the sane of mind and he
thinks this woman who is doing the thing
to him is his wife and it was just like
what is this yeah yeah it made me feel
like oh yeah this the NSA is watching me
and they're gonna judge me for this
what what pisses me off about this all
right what pissing me off especially
about this is that
it looks really [__] good like they
this is like for some reason for some
reason queen bee didn't pick this show
up yeah I think I think the scariest
thing about the show is knowing it was
like successful and it was popular
that's that's concerning dude I watched
this [__] in 1080P and I was just like
[__] yeah why did this 1080p version why
do they go so hard why do they have to
they could they could have kept it at
720 or 480 like all these other great
series but no this one we needed to see
an Ultra HD it's just like I I you
there's some things you watch
uh some some hentai you watch that
really make you think like man they're
really okay with them showing this but
we can't show a dick like we can we can
we can show this but I but you can't
show an uncensored penis yeah that's
where you draw the line but this is all
fair game all good oh so I was just
looking at my notes and that reminded me
of just like there is so you guys
obviously skipped the ugly bastard sex
scene
you know like I scrubbed with the mouse
thing and stopped any dialogue I know
exactly what was disgusting is aside
from the whole [__] head Titan thing
they gave him so much detail so much
there is this there is there's one
close-up shot that is like I I think I'm
going to have to go to like talk therapy
on this because this is one close-up
shot of his nipple and it is it is in so
much disgusting detail dude there's like
warts on that [__] and like even noticed
there's like one tiny nipple hair on it
and I'm like bro you did not you could
you could have just erased that one I'm
concerned about who this appeals to yeah
I'm concerned about who saw this and
thought finally a show for me like
that's concerning
you must have been uh clearly yeah it's
just like some animated make the
conscious decision to be like we can
make this worse we can make we can put
more detail on this dude I'm just I'm
just imagining the animator just hearing
it from the producer being like you want
me to draw what
I have to draw this and color it in and
animate yeah you know how like people
are like man I I don't care how people
can want to have sex sometimes I'm like
well [__] after watching this I don't
ever want to have sex ever again yeah
yeah there was one thing that didn't
make me laugh though at the end where it
was it was uh this at the end of episode
one where we it was the yandere right
that the husband was talking to yeah but
the the it was the husband and the Andre
at a bar
uh and the husband was like I think my
wife's like cheating on me I think I
think she's having an affair and the
girl just goes ah cheer up have a drink
that's very Japanese
literally yeah drink your sorrows away
bro don't worry about it it's like just
just don't be sad it's just simple just
get over it it was it was that image of
like tap and like the like the scissors
and the scissors yeah this is trying to
cut it it's just like just don't be sad
it's easy to go outside
um so yeah this uh I don't recommend you
watch this island but in fact I
recommend that someone invents a time
machine and goes back in time yeah and
uh prevents this anime from ever being
made I wish I still lived in a in an
ignorant world or full of bliss when I
know you guys I wouldn't I wouldn't
[__] have watched this if I never met
you guys like ever like I would never
have watched that ever I want to go back
in time where I'm like I can just look
at the image of the ugly Boston being
funny image yeah without knowing the
context behind it yeah God damn it all
right boys and girls Let's Get Serious
for a second we've Dalton trash takes a
lot about taking care of yourself
mentally which is why this episode is
sponsored by better help I'm in my 30s
now and in the past 10 years I sure as
hell felt like my life was growing and
changing and sometimes I felt a little
bit lost which is why at one point I
turned to talk therapy talk therapy is
about deepening your self-awareness and
understanding because we're all
complicated human beings and as much as
we'd like to think like we do sometimes
we don't even understand ourselves this
is where service like better help can be
useful betterhelp is an online service
that can connect you to a licensed talk
therapist that can help you on your
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are in my experience a lot of people
can find the idea of talk therapy
daunting and maybe a little bit
embarrassing I know I did way before but
sometimes just having a place where you
can talk freely and having someone who
can bring a fresh perspective on things
can help a lot because I know by my
experience guys we don't talk enough
about our emotions the great thing about
better help is that it removes that
daunting barrier of Entry entirely it's
entirely online to fit your schedule
it's flexible and designed to be
convenient and I want to reiterate a
very important Point here this isn't a
solution to all the problems in your
life it's just a tool to help you become
the best version of yourself so if you
want to give it a go discover your
potential today with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
help.com trash or just click the link in
the description thank you very much to
better help for sponsoring us today back
to the video well we thought I thought
it couldn't get worse but then it did
get worse with a you're a next
recommendation okay I want to preface
this is not a do I say recommendation
it's not a recommendation right I
I this show we're really going into this
one this show already this show I I
never felt more betrayed by a show in my
life yeah so straight up what was your
category uh it was name a MILF hentai
you didn't like yes yeah and uh what was
the name of this one again I forgot it
was uh Sleepless uh mid-summer
mid-summer so I yeah okay first of all
uh that's that's what it made me off
yeah I'm definitely Sleepless I'm gonna
be real I watched this one uh a most
most times I watch I don't have
subtitles right yeah so a lot of the
times I'm missing out in the fine
details I hear a lot but then this one I
went back to re-watch because I was
really confused why it went the
direction it did what the story is yeah
yeah but so here was my understanding of
the story
um before I kind of got to episode two
and this is what I was excited for it
because I was high so it opens with a
kid getting attacked it's all burned in
my memory by the way yeah it opens up
the kid getting in the taxi and he's
like you know he's in like the middle of
nowhere kind of in Japan he goes to the
cab driver he's like all right take me
to this mana and he's like bro the MILF
it is literally of [__] milk I'm like
you say bro you sure you're going with
the MILF manner a lot of the people
don't come out when they go there he's
like take me to the MILF Manor
henceforth go
what other what are other words
faster so they get to the mansion and
it's it's pretty high it's pretty
[__] high the first episode hype oh
it's great so it's like the first
episode you meet this maid she's great
yeah really attractive yeah uh they go
in the Onsen together get a little
frisky yeah it's great they didn't I
love it I love it when hentai when they
don't do sex right away yeah I love it
when they have an interaction and it
doesn't lead to sex yeah I'm like
classic it's like a little tease you
made me you made me stick around yeah
also one thing I really really liked
about this hentai like initially is that
it has a very very different art style
that doesn't look like every other copy
of hates it so much because I feel like
a lot of hentai right now has gotten so
homogeneous right in terms of their
character designs you know it's everyone
looks like the same copy paste everyone
has like a [__] buffer on their skin
to make it extra shiny and all the
characters are unique yeah this one
looks really unique really unique it was
I feel like it was like a nice mix of
like kind of the 90s hentai Style with
like upon style or yeah like mixed in
yeah every character in this Mansion was
just like a 10 out of 10. dude right
great yeah I mean like the first one my
favorite was the maid yeah yeah and we
had a scene right away with the maid and
I was like yes yeah I loved it because
she was kind of like I mean I guess if I
have to yeah yeah I always think that's
you know I don't know why I like that
but yeah it's kind of hard yeah and it
was fun and they didn't and she's like
no I'm not gonna have sex with you and I
was like
we'll get to that because like I was I
was very very much enjoying the first
episode yeah but in the scene with the
mum I was just like something made you
feel uneasy something made me feel
uneasy and I was just like I've seen a
lot of [__] scenes before an anime
but why does she keep like sucking his
dick kind of like a straw that's weird
yeah that's weird yeah I was like maybe
it's like a maybe maybe it's just uh
maybe it's a finish yeah maybe it's a
finish the thing that made me a little
uneasy was that
um they have this spray which is Viagra
spread yeah yeah
your PP recover after you know doing it
and I was like oh yeah well I'm sure
they're just like having sex a lot yeah
yeah and that was great because we've
got plenty of scenes and the mom was
great mom was super I loved her just
yeah in general I wish she was real that
was great it was good seeing hi dude you
cannot believe uh how hyped I was for
episode two and I because I watched this
when it came out right literally like
Day Zero I was there no patience zero I
was refreshing because I was at the
midnight screening I was waiting why was
it the midnight screening with the other
comments right we were all hype we were
like we're all shaking hands in our
suits like great another successful no
font it's been months since we've had a
good mil fan literally it had been it
had been and I cannot preface this
enough 2022 had literally no good MILF
hentai at all there was like there was
like one or two tops that were passable
right and this finally felt like we were
getting one we were getting this the
golden MILF experience well we've been
waiting for it
yes it was like MILF MILF Mana IRL get
that [__] out of here we finally got a
real one yeah and then I waited after
three months episode two finally came
out you can imagine how excited I was
you can imagine boy you can imagine how
excited I was
and then what I saw what happened when I
saw what they did I couldn't believe it
I never felt so disgusted
this not only did it not live up to my
expectations like Masterpiece three
which is already I will get into that
later yeah but it was like they they
took a 180. I I'm so I'm so disgusted
from MILF Manor to just some of the most
like just it was sore yeah it was sore
it uh I would say it was closer to
hostel because there unfortunately there
was no way this guy was gonna came out
um we watched Euphoria I'm not gonna lie
I think this one was even grosser for me
you know what I kind of agree I it's
it's it's definitely on that same yeah
yeah this just hurt more because I was
also invested like I was I was I was
there this is like if if like I was like
a Mario Kart fan I found out that like I
don't know like Mario like kills
everyone after the race dude I feel I've
never been click baited by hentai so
hard no did you when I when I explained
this to you guys it could because I
warned them I was like dude it gets
gross and I was like and I was like it's
it's Connor I've seen euphoria
to set the scene to set the scene
um I'm gonna explain this like a doctor
uh to set the scene how episode one ends
on a cliffhanger and it's great because
he's done the maid he's done the MILF
yeah and then now he gets to do the
daughter okay and now it's now it's like
uh now it's like a cliffhanger it's like
oh what what how's the daughter gonna be
she seems like she has a little bit of
an attitude
I was okay with like not really
exploring her because I really want my
film Yeah Yeah my two favorites yeah
yeah we got it yeah yeah
um and then so you load up episode two
you're like okay let's see where this
goes um and then starts off pretty
starts pretty okay you know she sprays
some more spray on his dick and she's
blocking him a bit weird talks with me
talks to him little bit weird you like
something seems a bit off but I'm sure
I'm sure uh I'm sure it's just normal I
know I think the family's just weird
um and then she brings out this
contraption
death dude I'm scared she uh brings out
this contraption and she says I want to
drink some tapioca milk tea That's what
she says oh yes I I forgot it she's like
I'm thirsty she she is thirsty and she
wants to drink some milk tea so she
brings out this contraption which is a
syringe with some tapioca in it and some
liquid in it uh with a long tube and
then proceeds to shove the tube up the
guys you know what and I'm not talking
about his ass
I believe the uh I believe the
scientific term for it is called
sounding
I think that's the tone for it if you
know what that means you know what that
means so it is uh it is
it it says
urethra yeah that and then she injects
the Boba yeah and then she proceeds to
inject the Boba and the liquid
into into this
um and
yeah that uh that that is that is when
you see all the details of it going in
and just and she drinks it afterwards by
making a knot with Boba I guess in yeah
and the dialogue is just it's awful it
is engine juicy like after after he like
gets it out of his system
she's like I want a little uh fresh milk
with this one yes and then he proceeds
to climax into the glass and she's just
casually sipping on this thing and I'm
like bro what is wrong I I I'll admit
right I I'm gonna say I like it just in
case you worry about that um I was like
maybe maybe that's just the one gross
thing that happens I'm gonna skip past
this and it just got worse and then when
the maid comes in oh I don't even think
let's say let's say the maid comes in uh
there is a banana which the maid is
forced to put somewhere and then let's
say maybe he had a bit of Taco Bell the
night before and then and then that
comes out
very important detail the banana goes in
a place and then the dude has to help
push the banana in with this peepee okay
okay for what okay I I was I was
grasping onto anything that I could like
hang on to for like me to take my mind
off the situation and thankfully like I
was like this is there is no way this
banana is keeping its shape this dude
shoves this banana in with his uh with
his pee pee and it perfectly maintains
its shape during everything
obviously right after you've had a
Tapioca drink you eat a banana sundae to
wash it down a banana chocolate sun and
so that's what comes out and um they
they eat it and then you're like oh my
God and then somebody like well that's
at least the worst is over oh it doesn't
get what it certainly gets worse yeah
because in the next scene they just go
to an operating table oh yeah so there's
a secret room in this manner that in
episode one it's behind this white door
and the maid says to the guy whatever
you do don't enter through this white
door it's it's a secret room but
obviously when when that gets pushed
down your throat
you get a little curious and so one
night he wakes up after he's force-fed
this banana chocolate smoothie he wakes
up and he he in a stupor he goes oh I'm
gonna go check out this room
and uh goes down into a [__] sasas
basement and there's just like test
tubes yeah there are dismembered
um penises and tits just uh just
floating about I I don't know like uh
this is this is a very weird subject
it's like I I was on board and I don't
know who this second episode's for like
Psychopaths clearly I think it was to
[__] over people like me I think I think
they wanted to [__] and ruin they were
definitely just trolling I think they
wanted the troll people yeah yeah I I
said the last hentai I think was made to
limit test erections uh I think the
person that made this just has a
vendetta against it right yeah I think
they won I I if anyone nutted to this I
genuinely am concerned yeah yeah it's
because like the thing the thing that
makes this so bad is just how much
detail they put into these scenes like I
remember that that first scene with the
tube I could feel the entire male
population entire just like I like
collectively grabbed a crotch area and
go oh and I remember as well like when
she's like when she's putting it in she
goes don't squirm or I might make a hole
somewhere else and I'm like ah yeah
you're like I'm pretty sure one like
Yoda said he fills the disturbance in
the force this like they were animating
this scene you know this when we think
like how are we allowed to show that but
we're not allowed to show a dick
you're pushing it again like what is
this
just the double standards it's like I I
could not explain how angry I was and
how ashamed I was and then the final
scene right where he I turned it off by
this point oh okay so I I sat through it
to the end because I was like how could
this get any worse
so basically what happens is he gets not
he so he sneaks into the the test tube
room right and he's like oh God I gotta
get the [__] out of here as he's about
to escape from the room a mysterious
Shadow like comes in knocks him out he
wakes up on the operating table and he's
he's fully naked and he is inside the
mom
and he's like wait something feels
strange about this and she goes yeah
don't worry about it we replaced your PP
with a much better PP
the much better PP is what I can only
describe
oh wait I remember that as a extremely
flaccid 15 feet long tentacle looking
[__] that just like slithers out
okay
was it like a completely different color
as well that was a completely different
color they gave him a black [__]
and it's a comically large black I just
I think my I think I think mine mine was
broken at this point because I just
full-on started my first hour
I thought I didn't read it as that I
thought it was like a a decrepit dick
that is like it was like gone from like
uh bro it was so soft I'm like how did
that thing stay here it is it is so
comically large it is basically like a
horse cop they gave him a black hole
it's bigger than a horse [__] man
I just this thing slithers out like a
snake
and he's just like what have you done to
my [__] and we've like
it's all pacifier
yeah we've built it stronger like better
like you know when people have those
arguments they're like man we shouldn't
change things in anime because we
shouldn't censor because it's part of
the culture I'm like [__] like this is
like absolutely not 100 we should censor
this stuff yeah what are you talking
about did she it is [__] and then and
then as well the final final scene is
like the main and the the mom or the
daughter I don't know at this point all
three of the the ladies are just In
Cahoots yeah yeah yeah and and of course
they have to insert a straw and into the
end of his pee pee again and just being
like just like like they're sharing a
[__] like cocktail on them a very
long straw it is
but considering how massive this uh this
horse penis is they got one of the crazy
straws I
they made this how do you get someone to
sit there and animate that like these
animators are chat I wanted to be in the
boardroom when this was pitched I didn't
believe it episode one about everyone
was on board they're like yeah that's a
resounding success gentlemen we've done
it again and then this one was just like
what and then and then the director went
on a [__] Coke bin he just came back
and he was like this I've got an idea
like there's no way they they they made
this and people did not need to go to
therapy after it like yeah I refuse to
believe you could animate this and not
have like consequences oh yeah
this was this is the first time where
I'm like oh this is this is what nsfl is
like this is this is this is not safe
this is not safe for life
um
it's just the thing that shocks me is at
least with other like messed up hentai
that I've seen at least with other shows
you get that tone from episode one no
this was yeah
I don't I don't read the tags when I
watch anime yeah I just click on it and
scroll through right yeah um and and
yeah so I was I was great I was man I
can't get over how to portrayed I was
yeah oh yeah I saw backstabbed man you
know like sometimes when I watch like
those Netflix documentaries about people
getting like betrayed or screwed over by
someone I'm like man I've never never
felt that way but this way made me feel
it yeah because like when you when you
recommended this to me and I saw that it
was not the word well when you suggested
this show to me I'm gonna put this right
out of there when you suggested to me
with the pretense of this is a milf
hentai that Conor didn't like right yeah
and I watched episode one and I was like
wow his standards have gone up oh my
and then episode two kicked in I'm like
ah yeah now I understand yeah there is I
felt bad that I'd make you guys watch
that yeah yeah it was it was a horrible
day to have eyes yeah it was nice
because I felt like I got to share a
trauma at least for my friends so that's
nice I can all go to therapy together
now I mean we all understand the pain
and the suffering I just unfortunately I
don't think we can go to a nonsense
again because I think my dick has Now
inverted back into my body oh it
definitely did yeah it does not want to
come out yeah absolutely
chastity belt is on now like I don't
want to anymore hello I'm a good we are
good Christian boys now we do not watch
him just like man we didn't have a
single good MILF hentai last year yeah
no Banger and that's what yeah and
that's all we got episode one was the
best we got yeah and then and then it
ends with uh another
unsuspecting kids being like take me to
the mill like take me to the MILF house
I want to go to the MILF house and now
we know if someone asks you to take you
to the MILF house no matter how good
that sounds you say no yeah that's why
I'm not watching MILF Manor I just I
just I'm destroyed anyway
holy [__] but I just is there anything
else we want to say oh come on can we
can we wipe this one yeah I want to get
rid of this yeah first time where I'm
jealous of Men In Black where I can just
[__] puke yeah this is why I want
right yeah yes
um I suppose I should uh go on to um the
hentai that I recommended okay uh which
is a little bit of a curveball because I
got uh the category name something
that's awoke something in you so I was
sure I took that as a hentai that has a
pretty like something I wouldn't usually
watch but then I watched it and I was
like I don't know why I kind of [__]
with that
um so do you want to explain the basic
premise of the show yeah I'm trying I'm
trying to get the name again I think
it's I think it's called sakub
yeah yeah so
um which means uh semen collection
Hospital what is the word for semen
again see it oh oh okay yes
you learn something new every day yeah
okay that's cool so another word to not
remember yeah so I'd say this this is a
simple pretty easy premise you know you
have a guy who has this weird ass
medical disc Condition it's this
weird-ass medical condition they didn't
really this is the average Twitter user
the average do you want to use that so
like so like you're not you know okay
I'm gonna you know in speed people have
seen speed where there's this bus right
but uh if if this bus goes below 50
miles an hour the bus will explode yeah
so imagine that with a guy's dick okay
so he doesn't jack off every three hours
yeah yeah his balls literally explore
so I don't know why I don't know if this
probably is not I really hope this isn't
a real medical condition
of course it is not real uh but yeah
this guy is a medical condition where if
he doesn't if he doesn't ejaculate every
three or so hours the then his nuts will
explode just literally just like and I
assume like the hospital will explode
with him I don't know I don't know if
the severity of the explosion yeah yeah
he'll probably just die and you might be
thinking to yourself well that's an easy
solution yeah he can just jack off every
three hours yeah no no they've figured
out that plot Hole by breaking both of
his hands yeah he's in this hospital and
he just has no hands yeah he has a he
has nuts that are about to explode and
two broken casting hands so he can't do
anything yeah and the closer he gets to
the three hours the more searing pain
his nuts are in yeah so it's it's it's
kind of like it's like kind of like a
ticking time it's whiny the whole time
yeah he was a [__] he was a little
[__] yeah yeah but uh so the main
premise of this is of course he has he
has to get the nurses to uh to take care
of this condition for him sure and we've
seen some variations of this hentai
before I feel you know you have like a
nurse whose job it is to take care of a
medical position and then oh they get a
get a little frisky the nurse starts
liking him maybe but no this one the
nurse hates the job she hates him and
you think okay maybe in the end maybe
and then she starts enjoying it she
starts like turning around maybe like
she sees the side of the guy that she
starts like no she hates him from
beginning to end and she is not afraid
to say how disgusting this [__] boy
is yeah and I was just like I I got it I
I saw this and I was I remember I
remember watching this I was waiting for
the turn you know I was waiting for I
was waiting for like the emotional turn
that we've seen with the girl yeah and
it's like it just never happens yeah so
this main girl just has to basically
make him
poor nurse you're not getting paid
nearly enough yeah that's to make him
ejaculate yeah so yeah so again like
this was another one where I was
initially confused right and I'm still a
bit confused where I watched all three
episodes by the way oh really I only
really liked the first one yeah yeah
because I I watched the first episode
and I was waiting for the turn and I was
like oh this is the thing that made
something awoke in God and I'll and all
I thought at the end of episode one was
are you okay guys no no no no no I I
kind of get it I don't get it at all I
get it really I'm gonna speak for Ghana
here
I don't know what it is I don't know if
gone has this too all right there is
something kind of attractive about how
she doesn't want to do it yeah really I
don't know why it's the disguster which
she she shows is kinda attractive I
don't know why I don't thank you
someone's I was afraid I was afraid I
was gonna get clowned up but like
something about just the disgust and not
having the turn I was like I don't know
what and again in real real life I would
absolutely despise this because in real
life I I just it's gross yeah I think
it's viable because like you know if
they don't like me I'm not into it in
real life yeah in the show of the way
it's portrayed I can understand again I
wouldn't jack off to it but I I
understand that you would find that
attractive oh I am the complete opposite
of that yeah like I I watch this and I'm
like wow this what a [__]
everyone in the show is a [__] you
didn't watch episode two or three did
you no okay that sure she was actually
the nicest
because at the end of episode one when
she leaves she's like you know I'm
actually one of the few nurses that's
quite tolerable and I'm like yeah it
gets worse oh it gets worse dude it like
opens up right and she's like oh fine so
she like Jacks him off and it's like
okay cool yeah scene ends yeah and he's
like oh I need to pee I can't pee and
then it's so pathetic and then he's like
I'm done peeing and she's like goes the
toilet and holds his PB up he's not
helping people he's like but I wanna I
wanna I wanna come I want to know oh my
God fine and she's like you're
disgusting you're disgusting whatever
yeah he goes like [__] everywhere and
then later on for some reason I don't
know why it kind of escalates and then
she is willing to do it with her mouth I
don't know why no no it's because he's
like I've jacked off so much in my life
yeah that I need something stronger yeah
I need more sensation I need to level up
and she's just like [__] you and he's
literally Beggars cannot be choosers bro
you do not get the desire yeah yeah yeah
and yeah I I don't know just like there
is like there's like a there's like a
kind of like dojin series which is like
uh that this really really reminds me of
is it the the panties one yeah like I
should like I can't remember the full
name but it's just like I'd make a
disgusted face while I show you my
panties or something like that and
normally it's just like a series of
images but this perfectly this is the
one this is the only hentai I've seen
that has perfectly captured the energy
of this one dozen Series where yeah and
it's became an anime right yeah it did
become yeah yeah and the whole premise
of this anime is that uh for some reason
uh the girls have to sh it's like it's
actually like a POV it's a POV anime so
it's done so it's almost like you are
talking to this girl and you're trying
to convince this girl to show you uh to
show her her panties to you right uh and
then the premise is you convince her to
do it she shows it and she's just
disgusted at you she hates it yeah and I
feel like this this for some reason this
hentai the this one episode the entire
episode is just I feel like it's based
it must be based on this Dojo I thought
I thought for a split second because I
also thought up of that show as well
because it definitely gave off the same
Vibes and I'm like is there a
possibility that it's done by the same
author yeah and I looked it up and it
wasn't but I was like it must have been
like I guess this is like a genre that I
never knew about and that people are
into and I'm like all right you know
who's also insanely well animated it was
like it was like there's a show I'll
give it that yeah you've seen where you
like it they do it and then she like
cleans herself out and it's insanely
well animated for some reason yeah I
don't know why but also there's a scene
in this that happens about halfway
through where the nurse is kind of
talking [__] about having to do this
yeah and he's outside listening and then
he walks in he's like hey why are you
saying bad things about me you know well
you don't like doing it and she's like I
literally have told you every single
time I [__] hate you and and it's
like what do you want from her yeah she
is a nurse who has to jack you off no I
I remember the exact thing he said he
was like I I don't feel good because uh
you don't feel good about doing this and
I'm like [__] thank you yeah bro this is
your Affliction yeah she is not getting
paid enough to do this yeah she just
does not want to do this I imagine she's
a medical professional who now has to
apparently become a pseudo prostitute
because your dick don't work yeah I I
think that's why I think that's kind of
why this works I feel like this was I
feel like this would have worked less if
she was just like a [__] yeah it would
have been uh just annoying yeah if she
was just a [__] to someone who was just
not doing anything wrong yeah yeah but I
was like looking at this guy seeing this
[__] beta being like
this isn't enough can you like give me
more yeah it's like bro what are yours
yeah it's like bro come on and like her
just being like I hate you you are
disgusting you are a pathetic worm and
I'm just like I don't know I don't
disagree yeah I don't disagree I'll give
him that I'll give it that like because
the guy was such a [__] boy like I I
felt for the girl and it made it be like
yeah girl [__] don't take [__] from
this guy but like maybe maybe I should
empathize more with the guy with a a
three-hour deck limit and not broken
hands no no no he can say what he's
getting like oh my my dick's not
sensitive enough to come with you like
jacking me off I don't like bro
did you want me to go to the MILF Manor
and get the spray like exactly right
yeah no but but I think like I I get
that I completely get like you know
because of the fact that the guy was
such a little [__] right yeah where
it's like okay yeah this girl has every
right to be mean as [__] to the guy yeah
it was hot yeah but like hot take I like
my hentai where the women like it
here's the thing here's the thing okay
here's the thing I I agree with you I I
normally agree I normally agree yeah um
because you know normally if the girl
doesn't like it
um then it's [__] NTR or something
right it's just like the complete
opposite of course I feel this was
closer to just emotionless sex right
yeah yeah yeah this this I I normally
I guess because like even emotionalist
sex like it's not as because there was
an emotion it's not quite in fact there
was a lot of emotion in this it's just
the complete opposite of emotion of it
was one it was disgusting yeah which I
don't really like in any context
personally yeah no I I get back
um I was surprised that I found it hard
because I was just like I ain't really
like into that kind of stuff in real
life I hate that [__] yeah yeah I was
like it's like to me I'm like I want to
stay away from that stuff I want a girl
to be like in it with me you know I want
to have a good time together which is
why you know I chose this hentai for
this one category because it's the only
hentai I've seen that has fully
committed fully fully committed to just
the girl being disgusted okay and so
episode two and three yeah it follows
the same guy ah yeah it follows the same
guy [__] baby but like the girls just
get progressively more sadistic yeah
yeah how does it get wow wow you can
even give me a question or the kind of I
guess whatever first things is that you
know they obviously uh somebody just
gets transferred and I was curious to
see how it was so that's why I came to
even watch it yeah and there's a girl
who's clearly like a bit evil she's
laughing at him calling him like a loser
and [__] yeah and then she deserves she
uh
Jacks him off and then uh she takes a
video of her doing it and she's like oh
if you don't if you don't start
appreciating it I'm gonna post this
everywhere oh [__] so in six hours you
better start groveling to me yeah uh and
he's like what are you what why
did I just say like Morty's voice every
time
and then so she comes back and he's like
oh I I would I know I don't think I
appreciate it I just need to I just need
to come and then she's like all right
fine so she jacks him off and then puts
the that the excrement in the uh in his
food and then starts feeding it to him
but then he doesn't want to eat it and
then she's like all right well if you
eat me you can eat the food and so she
starts pouring it it's gross it's so
nasty yeah I'm good dog uh and then it
kind of gets worse and there's one point
that it really made me laugh it was he
kept going like I want old nurse back I
want a bag she was cool I feel so down
that she's like oh you want a bang oh
you want a bag fine and then she he
takes time he takes him to her locker
and she makes him she's like jacking him
off and she's like you better you better
not all over her clothes I don't know
why he [__] like like a [__]
turret like a machine gun she's like
the nurse comes up she's like bro what
the [__] and then he's like haha and
then she starts jacking him off on her
she's like bro what the [__] collateral
yeah and it's just like what the [__] is
this it's so [__] dumb but it keeps
getting more sadistic and then yeah yeah
and then the third nurse goes into like
electro shock there electroshock therapy
yeah and it goes down that route so it
just gets it at like it gets closer and
closer just like yeah yeah she puts a a
flashlight on a power drill and then oh
yeah just turns it and then turns it on
on this and he's just and it's just like
it's like it's like a cotton candy
machine of nuts yeah it's just going you
know cotton candy comes out like imagine
that bit of a flashlight just going
everywhere it's it's it's like a band
most critical Contraption
Charlie is like nah this is going to
[Music]
honestly like it's it was that third
like because it like like I said I'm not
really into this kind of stuff but the
first episode had that perfect balance
you know what you know yeah you know why
it's right because when she said I'm one
of the good nurses yeah I I believed it
yeah
I was like you know what she has taken
care of yeah maybe she didn't appreciate
as much she wanted but I think she did a
job yeah I didn't torture you I think
she could didn't you didn't honestly
above and beyond honestly honestly she
did the fact that she like she did every
request that he asked even though he was
a little beautiful [__] baby
boy yeah absolute her before he's he's
the herbivore that gets eaten by her
before like holy [__] and she put up
with that [__] and she just did her job
she was a professional from start to
finish yeah okay did she verbalize her
did she leave she's a little harsh yeah
did she what did she verbalize her
thoughts of course she's definitely
underpaid okay maybe maybe then episode
one will awake me if I watch episode two
and three and I look back at it
retrospectively and being like a
retrospective boner yeah and I'm like
you know what now I think about it yeah
that's all right you know and you know
what if there are any other anime that
even like closely resemble how like how
balanced this first episode is kind of
interested because I don't know I'm like
I thought it was really well done yeah I
thought it was really well done piques
my interest and I'm like I can't really
think of any other Handler like this
Japan is really good at doing that and
then just [__] it all up right away
oh yeah they're just ruining it yeah
yeah but yeah that's that's that one I
definitely worth a watch yeah uh I think
I think this was the one episode yeah I
think I think the episode first episode
is worth the watch second and third
episode
it goes it loses that balance but
another show that is definitely worth a
watch complete opposite reaction is uh
my final one which was uh recommend a a
dubbed hentai that's actually good yes
and uh man it was so hard to just pick
one if I'm there a lot of good ones
there's a lot a lot of them are
fantastic for for the wrong reasons for
the wrong reasons we're gonna we're
gonna end this on a good note yeah one
more after this yeah but like you know I
could have recommended like you know
classic going back to the classics Bible
black dub which is [__] hilarious
yeah but I I think there's only one that
it just just crowns at the top and it's
a little series called sextra credit
and uh this dub is the ghost stories of
hentai like this this thing this dub is
absolutely incredible because of just
how self-aware the script writers were
yeah and just how bad the show is so I
guess the original premise is that
there's a teacher and originally the the
high school
um principal was an old man yep and he
left and was replaced with an all-female
student council uh a president whatever
yeah so to look over the school and he's
[__] pissed about this because they
don't like him and so I guess the
original plot because the the dub kind
of just changed the entire plot you've
seen the original plot I I I was so
confused by what I watched that I wanted
to find out what it was actually because
you could watching it you can tell yeah
oh this isn't what it's supposed to be
and so I went up I went and researched
what it was it was actually supposed to
be yeah yeah and I found out that
um because the original was so actually
disgusting it's so gross and it's so
despicable like it's it is nothing
redeeming about it and they try and
paint the main character as some kind of
hero yeah when all he's doing is um our
wording uh all this people and doing
horrific [__] yeah yeah and it's like
and so when they got to the dub they
were like [__] no we're not we're not
doing it like this we're gonna remake it
and make this guy a [__] loser and
make fun everyone's a piece of [__]
because this is just [__] this is
gross like and if we're gonna dub it we
may as well at least make it all [__]
stupid yeah Venus yeah
um and so for some reason he wants to
take revenge on all of them uh and so he
slowly does that one by one by
blackmailing all of them uh into doing
uh things with him yep and he slowly
gets more sadistic as The Show Goes On
yeah but in the dub it's not that at all
no um in fact it is some of the funniest
dialogue you'll ever see yeah so yeah so
you've probably seen and compilations
like YouTube clips and honestly just
watch that like I even watching the the
sex scenes in this did not there was one
or two more funny lines yeah yeah but
the whole show was so gross uh that I
just honestly the YouTube thing just
leave it at that that's funny yeah it's
it's and it's funny for the wrong
reasons like it's funny because he just
says stupid [__] and you can tell it's
obviously parodying the dumb [__] in the
show yeah yeah I mean the dialogue has
definitely uh not aged well let's just
say that okay let's just say I remember
the first scene uh where the first scene
is basically just this group of girls
like just
full-on like insulting this guy right
which is which I believe was yeah I
think not not what exactly happened in
the original yeah yeah I don't think so
but it's just it's just these four or
five girls insulting these guys uh the
best way I can describe what they say is
just these girls learn English from a
Call of Duty Lobby okay that's that's
kind of what is said in here my favorite
one is you have less spine than an
earthworm you've left spine than a spina
bifida Victor yeah
oh
[Music]
I has definitely no age well yeah this
show came out in 2004 uh yeah it
definitely uses some like Newgrounds
comment section uh levels of a language
that cannot fly today yeah it's it's a
it's a trip uh and not a good one
um even the dub is still just awful yeah
uh I I actually know what I was curious
when I watched it I was like man there's
got to be some funny reviews of this
show yeah and to my credit there was
um on Amazon
oh [__] and there was some funny uh
reviews if I uh recall correctly why is
it trying to change my location oh yeah
Amazon us hold on let me go in our
incognito tab let me open up these
reviews
[Music]
there was uh uh here we go here we go
here we go
um and the the headline of this is
properly describe your stock
two out of five stars my main problem
with this film that is improperly
described is listed you would think that
this is a variation of Harem style
however it is about as far from that as
possible this is a r slash Revenge
fantasy title and there was nothing to
indicate that if you were into that type
of story it works just fine however this
would be vastly improved if it was
indicated as such I would not buy it
again because I believe that the
customers should know what they are
getting especially in the field of
hentai and there's some other stuff you
know what valid valid my guy asked for
like tags yeah like I was like yo where
are the tags he was like he was like
where's the sauce yeah where's the sauce
for this someone also said four stars
sweetheart
what yeah another one said uh a decent
animation uh another one said exactly as
described five stars okay standard
review section okay okay someone said he
loved sexual credit on DVD and he want
more who is he this is a guy from the UK
as well I don't know who this is you
know if you start talking in third
person that's right
yeah but like I just I I feel like this
is like whoever got there
whoever got their hands on a license for
this one has just lived my dream because
I've like this is what I wish I could
have done yeah dude I wish I could
because you know 100 if you watch this
some of the lines that I said it is the
script writing how the scriptwriters
having as much fun as possible they are
they do not hold back uh with the jokes
because there isn't there ain't no if if
you actually jacked off to this I'd be
more impressed if you jacked off to this
than some of the other end times how are
you going to stop yourself from laughing
yeah it's like trying to jack off to an
Adam Sandler film it's like it's
impossible like you can't do it you've
just been laughing the whole time there
was there was one scene where and also
man with these teachers weird oh yeah
there's this one scene where I guess the
teacher is just having orgies with all
the students yeah oh yeah and then he
films it and then that's what he uses to
get her to do stuff with him yeah and
then there's another thing where
I just like
I don't know what the vial is supposed
to be in the in the Japanese one yeah he
whips out a vial of red liquid and in
the English dub and he's gonna pour it
on the girl's area of uh of Interest
let's say and in the English dub he
refers to it as barbecue sauce with
Tabasco
and I think it's supposed to be
something else in the Japanese one and I
don't dare go to watch it because I
actually don't want to find out what
it's supposed to yeah what if you go to
the Japanese one he's just like yeah and
he goes I put extra [__] Tabasco in
this one and then he says a line that a
genuinely like broke me and he goes
there's so much barbecue sauce inside of
you what you it was something like if
you're in a corn on the cob inside of
you now it'd be a complete barbecue or
something
like that and it was just like what the
[__] is this dialogue oh but okay so
even what you watching you've watched
the uh sub of this right so this I I
know I watched the dub subtitles okay
okay uh so so you watch the uh raw so I
went to go and read the premise of what
it was and I watched two minutes and I
was like I'm done okay this is so gross
because because one thing that I I was
confused about by the plot of this right
is you know the first girl uh the the
first girl that he finds
um and uh and uh he I guess violates
yeah
um she ends up just like doing wanting
it 180 and just immediately joining him
yeah yeah I didn't get that yeah yeah
and obviously the dub makes fun of this
right because it's [__] ridiculous
and why like in the dub they just goes
why did you sodomize me or something
like or something like that it's so bad
no and then there's the scene of them
like sitting on the bed and and she's
like hearing all of his frustrations
yeah
there's a line that just [__] killed
me he was just like wow you're really
understanding for someone who just got
all wood
like without knowing the story like yeah
I think even as like the dab alone is
still gross yeah this show is actually
so vile yeah
um in general yeah but I think even if
just seeing the job it still doesn't do
it justice but then knowing the context
as to why they changed all the lines
yeah makes me just think did these dudes
are Giga chats oh they just saw this
terrible gross product and they were
like
I do not want to give I do not want to
appeal to this fantasy let's just let's
just [__] it up and let's just make fun
of all of this yeah I do not want anyone
to get bonus yeah let's just make
everyone there's a reason why there's a
hilarious compilation of all of the
dunkers it's insane yeah out of context
it is so like what the [__] did he just
say there are there are like so many
there are so many like golden lines in
this I think another one I think another
one which which is just like this is
what Andrew season his mind eyes
which is I'm a man with a set of balls
and I demand to be treated with respect
yeah that made me laugh so [__] much
it's probably one of the only ones I
genuinely recommend you watching if not
just for like the YouTube company don't
watch the set just just watch the just
use just watch the YouTube compilation I
think it's called This is the greatest
hentai dub of all time yeah the greatest
dub of all time yeah it's so the out of
context it's funny yeah uh but in
context It's just sad yeah it's a [__]
show that some someone just went you
know what I'm actually going to make
this somewhat enjoyable and you know
what I think they did a pretty pretty
okay they salvaged like a a car crash uh
going into a group of Orphans uh on a
plane that's crashing yeah yeah and then
at least we Salvage the steering wheel
yeah all right we managed to land the
plane yeah yeah yeah which leads us now
to uh the final show that uh I guess we
force ourselves to watch the goat if you
will the goats the classic I think the
MILF Mana was worse than this okay I
think so for me so
so Euphoria is one of the most like
Infamous yes anime that has uh oh I
should say hentai that has been released
visual novel first yeah it was a visual
novel first and I remember like watching
this like this was this was that one
anime that everyone recommended to you
if you were like on in like
online back in like 2000 like the
mid-2000s anime it started with Boku no
Pica yeah and after that craze died down
craze died down yeah everyone was like
all right we got to find another one to
to troll the unexpected with yeah and
then some genius was like I saw I found
this show called Euphoria yeah still one
of my one of my favorite Twitter threads
to this day is uh the first time that
Sydney discovered Euphoria this was back
before she did YouTube this was back
before she was the queen of degeneracy I
remember one day she was just uh she we
were in Sydney's we were into this room
and she was like have you had this thing
called Euphoria and I was like yeah
why'd you ask and she was like people
keep recommending it to me why do people
keep recommending it to me and I was
like oh it looks uh it's a pretty
Infamous anime and uh it's a pretty
Infamous game as well and she goes oh
why is it Infamous and I was like don't
worry about it honey yeah and then so
what I what she and then she decides of
like curiosity oh just download the
vision of them played the visual novel
and I'm just like you should uh you
should uh tweet your live thoughts on
that honey let's let's see let's see
what you think yeah yeah she played the
visual like 30 hours long it's longer
than that yeah I've played it as well
yeah like played it yeah it's I got
curious man okay I have a question okay
this is supposed to make sense from the
anime alone no because I I swear bro I
tried and I don't know what was
happening I've watched this so many
times more than yeah
no yeah no it doesn't it it's not
supposed to make I'm not dumb like it's
not supposed to make sense I guess in
the Creator's Minds it's supposed to
make sense but like I played the visual
novel I've seen the hentai more times
than I'm proud to say and I'm just like
still don't get it yeah I understood
serial experiments Lane better though I
managed to figure out uh in the second
episode that I was kind of watching
different endings kind of different
different routes it was like but it was
like it was like The Abridged version of
the routes and then the ending that kind
of yes it was weird because it was like
I was like man I feel like we're just
going through the motions and it's also
not clear what's happening technically
speaking it's like the first four
episodes are the different routes you
can go on with like the different girls
and then episode five is the bad end and
episode six which is the final episode
is the true I thought it was the other
way around I I thought it was the other
one
I thought every episode had the good end
for each girl yeah uh and sometimes the
bad I don't know it's it's like to be
honest I don't remember yeah so so to
explain the basic premise of this yeah I
actually should do that yeah we should
do that before we get into like
um theories
a Euphoria Theory thanks for watching
thanks for jacking so uh it's very very
similar to I guess any kind of like
death game or saw or that kind of
premise okay it's hentai squid games
I saw his hentai saw it is it is more
deranged so yeah so what happens is this
guy wakes up in a completely white room
with I think like four or six guys
six originally okay and then one of them
refuses to participate oh that's right
with six girls and uh he basically has
to uh get out of this room by performing
various acts to a girl of his choosing
and obviously some of these acts can uh
range from I was gonna say pretty
vanilla stuff uh yeah pretty like
comparatively light stuff like oh just
uh put on a sexy like BDSM outfit and go
hard uh and some uh like uh I just saw
Contraptions some just saw Contraptions
like oh just be a human toilet and I'm
not going to explain what that is but uh
yeah they're already glossed over that
in the [__] shirt that's episode
thankfully yeah um and if they don't do
it then they die so yeah so they have a
they all have these collars I guess mind
control yeah which mind control and also
I guess if I remember correctly like if
they don't do what the the the master
you know the the game master says then
like I think they explode or they like
cut your head off or something it's
something like that basically yeah they
have this thing that's attached to the
neck that they can't get rid of so
they're basically at the will of the
game master yeah so so before we get
into too deeply into this how many
episodes did you watch of euphoria I I
sat down and actually watched fully uh
one or six but I skimmed through all of
them so like I I sat there and I was
like okay all right get it get it all
right all right so I kind of watched
most of it I mean you didn't watch
episode five which I did watch episode
five and I was very confused yeah okay
episode five is actually like I watch
you know because I I actually ended up
re-watching all of it because I was I
watched episode I watched episode one
and I'm like I need to refresh myself I
watched episode five and I was like am I
just like has it just been a super long
time since I watched this maybe I just
need to watch the previous episodes for
context I ended up watching every
episode I was like that didn't help at
all no like holy [__] episode five I
think is the end of Ava for [__] for
hentai like this this [__] made no sense
this [__] made no sense yeah and it was
like in one episode certain characters
were evil and good yeah and the next
episode they would Swap and I was like
why can we explain these things yeah and
it was just bad yeah it was just [__]
like I I don't even think it was like as
gross as some other stuff like I think I
think the the maid Mansion one was
grosser for me it was but I think the
one thing that to this day no matter how
many times I watched it that just pisses
me off about Euphoria is that God damn
it's so well animated yeah well the
first episode and the second episode
okay no then it went off a cliff no they
were all well I thought it was worse
animation at the end I I thought it was
pretty pretty good it's pretty
consistent episode three a damn good
animation I think his his here's the
[__] up thing right his his the [__]
up thing
um obviously the um the premise is
[__] up and everything of course okay
there are some scenes that is just uh
not safe for life I will not touch with
a 10-foot barge pole uh the worst thing
about Euphoria is that every so often
they'll sprinkle in what I think is a
actually pretty good scene like what
give me an example Give an example like
what like yeah it's an example of this
there is a scene at the end of like
episode three whereas like the main guy
and the girl with like you know
um the emotionless girl right oh yes
yeah and they and then and they just
have like I would say a pretty pretty
vanilla sex scene is that the one in the
bed right with the bedroom yeah yeah and
I'm like damn she she goes
yeah yeah and then she gets like
pregnant and [__]
yeah yeah we'll get to that we'll we'll
get to that no no this is this was
before I found out the plot twist of who
this girl was like all I'm all I'm
saying oh I just realized who she was
yeah because I connected the dots to
what they said in the last episode three
yeah
wait that's like how many years apart is
that then
okay that's just the theory
wait so how many years are they trapped
in this [__] sex game I don't know 10
[__] years I don't think it's ever
stated yeah it's it's never stated what
what I don't get is that like this dude
is the embodiment of like there are two
wolves inside of me and except except
both the Wolves want to do our word to
people yes this is this dude is
literally Ken kaneki if he was a hentai
protagonist you know it's like it was so
confusing all the time figuring out what
was real and what it wasn't yeah because
it would be like this is real no this
wasn't this was real none of this as
well yeah they tried to do like a
millennium actress thing where it's just
like you don't know if it's real or not
yeah it was so [__] it was [__] I I
don't even they like it's just boring it
was boring as well I actually thought
there was I wouldn't say it's boring I
wouldn't say I thought there were some
scenes I thought was pretty I okay I I
really liked nemu I don't know why uh
the first episode the first the first
episode girl uh yeah but I mean isn't
she in all of them she's not the main
focus of all right right in the first
episode yeah yeah I it's it's episode
one and episode five she's like the main
yeah I guess yeah yeah I remember first
time watching Euphoria I'm like man she
has a shit-eating grin and I was like oh
oh oh oh okay
I was not prepared for yeah when I saw
that I was like God
yeah so episode five they do like what I
can only describe as human centipede oh
this Euphoria did Human Centipede like
years before Human Centipede became like
a meme yeah
I definitely skipped over that yeah
because I remember I think I saw his
glimpse of it I was like nope yeah um
I'm gonna watch this yeah yeah so like I
don't know why
the story became so confusing
um but the basic premise is every in
every episode there's a different girl
with a different who I'm guessing they
follow a different route and some and so
and sometimes you get a happy ending and
sometimes you get a glimpse of the Bad
Endings as well but then they decide to
put both in one episode and that's that
was what was confusing too yeah it's
really [__] confusing yeah yeah all
of it yeah because then in episode six
they bring out this like sex cult that
comes out of nowhere yeah you're like
actually above ground is where we have
the cult and below ground is where you
guys are yeah see I I I thought I
thought being a fake fan I can I can
keep track of convoluted timelines and I
watch Euphoria and I'm like oh I know
nothing did this only get like popular
because of the centipede thing
no it got popular I think because it
because I think like when you look at
just the surface of it the art is really
nice the character designs are really
nice yeah the the premise is like I
think when Euphoria came out there was
very few hentai that had a premise as
just openly as [__] up as that right
okay one thing one thing I'll say
because a lot of the hentai we watched
today are for this episode they were
like 15 minutes long yeah and I was like
watching re-watching all of euphoria I
was like God damn I miss when hentai
were won half an hour in length and two
or like more than two episodes yeah
rewatching all of euphoria after all the
other ones we watched was like watching
the [__] Lord of the Rings I was like
God damn this is long it was too long it
was way too long the hours of the show
Jesus ten minutes in I was like God
so two and a half hours of this [__]
wow did you not even like the teacher at
all the little the teacher was are you
[__] you knew I was gonna
uh appealing to me but yeah you know I
usually I he didn't deserve it yeah well
I don't know man I don't know about that
what do you mean he didn't deserve it as
in like he didn't deserve any any able
to do anything he should have just died
like right away well would have a lot
shorter it would have been the story at
all uh yeah it would have been good it
would have been ended maybe he'd been
like you know what I respect these women
I'm not gonna do that yeah and then they
just all died and it's like cool yeah
better than what happened so what I what
I think was like the weirdest plot twist
was actually in episode six where we go
to the sex calls because we had like the
human centipede thing and obviously
that's [__] up
um I don't know what is they decided to
put that in but obviously like I believe
the human centipede was made as a
concept because they were thinking about
how best to punish like sexual predators
or something like that right so the fact
that someone in Japan made this to think
that people would jack off to this that
disturbs me more yeah yeah that disturbs
me more uh and then in in episode six we
find out that one of the girls who he
has been one of the girls who he's been
having sex with
um the one in episode three
turns out that she's the daughter of
um the leader of this sex cult who uh
who the main guy impregnated years ago
so essentially this girl is just his
daughter yeah yeah this guy this girl is
just his daughter and now that I realize
that literally just like five minutes
ago it's so nasty
and it's and it's extra disturbing to
think that episode three which involves
the daughter is probably the most
wholesome episode in the entire series
it is probably the most wholesome
episode and the one where you get the
most vanilla sex yeah and you're just
like oh wait oh oh no oh God but then it
also confused me when I found out about
that plot and I was thinking back to
episode three and like all the other
previous episodes
how old is this yeah it doesn't hurt
anything he looks like he makes no sense
he looks 15. yeah it doesn't it
literally makes no sense chronologically
yeah like it's not possible like did he
[__] her in a hyperbolic Time Chamber
like what yeah like that's the only
explanation maybe they're in a world
where like boys stop puberty at age one
yeah I don't I don't understand how this
is bought like it doesn't make [__]
sense and I'm glad it doesn't because
it's [__] stupid see what what I was
thinking here's here's my I can't post
it stop doing the math I was like it
doesn't matter here's here's my theory
okay here's my theory because there's
this really weird they do a [__]
Marvel post-credits scene in episode two
which is I don't know I don't I don't
know why I see this yeah probably
because you skipped it they did this
really weird thing and uh at the end of
episode two where nemu comes in dressed
like a scientist and one of the girls in
like a virtual reality like got a got a
VR headset right and it kind of frames
the entire thing as like an experiment
right so I don't maybe all this thing is
just happening in his mind maybe all
this thing is a VR experiment does that
make it less fat is still [__] up
because they're still animated okay it's
it's still [__] up because you know
what you know why because like they give
they frame episode six they frame the
entire episode as a good ending yeah
which is awesome ending and you know
what the [__] good ending is
he has two children with his daughter
that is the good end yeah that is the
vanilla ending that is that is the
vanilla ending of euphoria
um and I yeah I don't know if that's if
that's vanilla what the hell is the bad
ending is what I found like a like a
like a hentai plot written by a four
Channel and it somehow just got like
approved like that's what it felt like
it felt like a just a like a rookie I
don't know maybe it's good because when
I was looking on YouTube I was like I
need someone to explain this somebody
had like a 45 minute video being like
why euphora is actually a masterpiece
yeah like it wasn't I was like [__] off
it wasn't I didn't even count it as like
the good ending it's just the Lesser bad
ending yeah right or I guess the true
ending I don't know I'll say the episode
that pissed me off the most episode five
which you kind of see yeah yeah well I
saw the ending yeah and I was like what
yeah so episode the episode five genuine
this is why it's the end like this is
why it's the end of April of like hand
Cycles this dude is literally Shinji
okay this dude is literally Shinji so
what happens is like in episode five
they reveal I guess who the main
Mastermind of the games are yeah and so
she comes out she reveals herself and
she's like because they escape yeah
because they somehow one of the tiles is
loose and there's an underground Channel
yeah yeah and then she reveals herself
she reveals herself and she she's like
I'll give you the option you either kill
me or kill nemu who is the main girl of
that show or all of the other girls die
and I'm gonna continue killing people
until you choose to either kill me or
kill that girl yeah and he's like I
don't want to and it's the childhood
friend right yeah yeah yes the child
main character it's the childish
you could either kill a murderer or
somebody who's not a murderer
and it was literally just the [__]
Shinji get in the robot moment of just
like just do it oh my [__] do it the
choice is so obvious no matter who you
ask yeah and he just happens to be the
worst Choice he makes the worst choice
of doing nothing and the war happens is
that she proceeds to take out his three
of the other girls and he just they she
just decapitates them yeah in front of
them and then he's still like no I'm not
gonna do it no I'm not gonna do it
you're still my childhood friend we've
been good friends this is not the girl
you are you
and then they proceed to do the human
centipede thing yeah and the worst part
is he [__] ejaculates during the
human centipede moment that was a mister
that was that was the moment that I had
blacked out for my memory and then and
then and then after that he the girl
drugs the main guy and nemu yeah with
some kind of like sex crazed drug or
something yeah and and then at the end
of it all
he just snaps her neck mid-sex and I'm
like
every every option you have done this
entire way has just gotten worse and
worse and worse it was one thing I was
confused by where like I think she's
shot nemu with an imaginary gun or
something and she just dies oh yeah oh
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're trying to escape yeah she
pulls out a gun like a finger gun
they're like aha then it cuts to another
shot for holding a gun you're like wait
what
yeah yeah that's all simulation that's
why I was like this is some virtual
reality [__] going on man I'm waiting
for like I was waiting for like that big
plot twist drop and then it just never
happened no they gave us the plot twist
drop but they all but they just didn't
explain the twist yeah I I think the
reason why this got so popular is
because back in the day
um this was just at the time one of the
most messed up hentai that was available
and also really one thing is that you
know we we are [__] on the story but
they actually had a they they put a lot
of thought into this story it didn't go
in the right place it was it was [__]
but the effort was there the execution
was not I remember you know do you know
my first experience for Euphoria it
wasn't even like I didn't start with
episode one uh it was actually episode
three right and I remember I remember
like looking at the art style I was like
oh this looks this looks pretty good all
right all right let's let's see what
this is about look clicks epic like
clicks uh clicks an episode of this uh
this video which turns out to be episode
of episode three of euphoria I got click
baited by the [__] thumbnail I was
like oh okay let's see what this is
about the first scene is a girl getting
decapitated and I have enough I my penis
has never gone flaccid so fast holy [__]
dude you just got limewired yeah I did I
did it all starts with I'm not hand
sections
and that was my very first experience
with Euphoria so like that was like so
after that I was like you know I wasn't
even in the mood anymore but I needed to
Google what the [__] this was yeah
that's that's how I discovered and still
talked about to this day man and it's it
is still talked about to this day as uh
one of the most infamous uh one of the
most infamous visual novels and Anime to
be made the thing I will say is that I
feel like now
the visual novel was still like way
worse yeah so I feel like they glossed
over some of the most messed up scenes
from the visual novel like the like the
human toilet because there are multiple
human toilets yeah I'm good I'm gonna
skip this don't bother yeah don't um
this is the one time where I'm jealous
you don't like visual novels
I'm like you know what if I if I hit it
just as much as you I probably would
have where do you even get this visual
novel like I assume steam isn't selling
it
yo that was an 80 off on euphoria
like readily available how did you even
get this oh it's legally available what
yeah I think uh I think Sydney owns an
official copy and I think you can
download it legally as well if you're uh
if you're interested just watch uh see
these videos
oh my goodness there's a there's a lot
of websites that sell like even really
really old uh like arrogates and visual
novels that are properly licensed by the
creators but it's all just like
digitally
um that's how I got my hands on most of
them so yeah I paid for mine and that's
what I got so yeah just you know what
I've realized after watching all of
these hentai I can't drag off anymore
apart from that yes what I just like I
want I want an actual protagonist that
is like interesting for [__] sake
every protagonist that in this in these
hentai's are like the biggest betas of
all time the biggest hurts like Johnny
Sins just star on one of these hentai
yeah yeah I I want a Chad who is likable
yeah yeah like every Chad in hentai is
just the most detestable human yeah the
antiago yeah like the only Hensel I can
think of that's I mean I I don't know if
I'd call him a Chad but at least he's
like at least mildly Charming is rants
oh yeah Rance is the closest we'll get
to a protagonist where I'm like yeah you
know what he's an ass he's still an
[__] but you know what God damn
you're a lovable artist yeah yeah laughs
but yeah that was uh that was a journey
we uh spent an entire day watching oh
God watching seven hentai that we
definitely do not recommend anyone yes
our curiosity gets the best of you with
anything that we say in this video we
hold zero responsibility that's that is
up to you to decide we told you to not
watch it yeah and you didn't listen to
us there's there is one thing I will say
though uh because you know we're
probably gonna type this title with this
you know watch uh watching like the most
cursed hentai or something like that I
know there is always going to be that
one comment that is just like that's not
[__] up you guys are weak for being
[__] and for thinking that's [__] up
that's all cursed I'll show you
something cursed and I'm like that I
I've I've seen this I've seen this kind
of comment so many times yeah and I'm
like what game are you trying to win
yeah yeah what are you doing yeah that's
not something to brag about yeah yeah
because like you've seen this like with
threads of like [__] up movies or
anything and it just it gets to the
point where like the final stage just
like snuff films or some [__] right I'm
like why why do you want to be
emotionally distant to some of these
things you know that's I don't just
don't watch any of these I'm glad that I
am disturbed by some of the things we
watched because that means that I'm
probably still staying in the head yeah
like why are you trying to get bragging
rights this is something that just is
gonna result in you having no friends
because like the final level of this is
just something so messed up yeah and so
[__] up that you are probably gonna
have to call the police you know that's
there is there is no winning to this
game yeah
um so I was going to say that before we
get that comment because I just
guarantee we are someone someone was
gonna type that out
um are we thought that these were all
very cursed yeah I I wouldn't recommend
watching any of these yeah yeah we just
tortured each other for some reason yeah
we hope it was entertaining for you guys
but uh hey look at all these patrons
though yeah you guys fortunately or
unfortunately got to watch this episode
unsafe answered with the clips we talked
about yeah and uh if you're if you know
what if you're curious instead of going
out to watch these shows why not support
the boys in the meantime by going over
to our patreon patreon.com trash taste
you can get access to the uncensored
version of this episode and supporting
us in the process support you know pay
for our mental health thank you to the
patrons for funding our therapists yes
um that's that's that's all I can say
but uh yeah yeah
again go to patreon also follow us on
the subreddit send us some memes on the
Twitter and if you had our faceless on
Spotify I I need a lie down after this
one I need to lie down yeah all right
see you guys next week bye
thank you
[Music]